[Music]
[Applause]
oh he is
look there's a cop do you see him
it's okay it's gonna be okay he can help
us
do nothing okay
hi just trust me and get his attention
[Music]
pull your window down behind you
oh my god
can you see him he's catching up
[Music]
come on man go
you know what a courtesy type is young
man sounds like this it's light
it's friendly sure that's what your mom
meant to you no it's not
mom
having a kind of a hard time lately i'm
sorry
you accept my apology if you could just
do the same we could press reset i don't
have anything to apologize for
[Music]
can you go please
ma'am are you okay i'm pretty sure the
guy in that truck's following me
he's road raging why don't you just
chill man go your
way
i don't think you really know what a bad
day is
i'm sitting here i'm waiting for you
whose phone is i'm i crossed my friend
hey listen to me he's not a friend okay
he's a psycho who came
after me today this is where your first
lesson begins give me my phone
put him back on this goddamn phone no i
can't do that
what do you want i need you to learn
what a bad day really is
and i need you to learn how to say sorry
damn you're gonna learn
through violence and retribution sounds
like you're waking up
i'm quite awake you better bring your
a-game
gonna need it
[Music]
foreign